it's 11 40. let's get started
uh welcome everyone thank you for
joining this session
about git let's just
jump into it because i have a lot of
stuff to show you guys
so first my name is enrico campidoglio
i'm
a freelancer here is me freelancing from
home
i also do a fair bit of training like
yeah workshops conference conference
talks pre-outside courses stuff like
that
and these days everything is done from
home who would have thought
the other thing to know about me is that
i am really passionate about
git of all things and i'm also
really passionate about keywords but
that's another story for our time
however feel free to ping me if you also
share this interest
in either git or keyboards
anyway so let's talk about it about it
shall we
by the way everything that i do that has
to do with git
i tend to write on my website which i'll
give you a link for
afterwards okay so
the thing with git is everybody is using
it these days
uh that's no surprise it has become the
de facto standard
version control for everyone however
um you may or may not have noticed that
while everyone including me is busy
telling you
how git works um internally
nobody is really focusing on how you
should actually use it
on your day-to-day work so to give you a
metaphor imagine if you are learning to
play an instrument like for example the
piano
and you know everything about how the
piano works
everything from the ground up and you
maybe know
each individual note but then you don't
know how to play a full song
with it so yeah that doesn't really cut
it
so what we need is guidance
okay guidance on how to use this
fantastic tool
called git but wait a minute you say and
i can almost hear you from here
do i need guidance to use a source
control system
i mean i'm a software developer i know
how to check in and check out code
and yeah you will be right after all if
you've been using
any of the many other source control
systems out there
like for example cvs perforce
or everybody's favorite tfs you should
pretty much know how to use a source
control system so
why in the world would you need guidance
on how to use git which after all
is a source control system or
is it because the thing with git
is that git is actually not
a source control system from the
beginning
if you look in the manual git is
actually
a content tracker also a stupid one
because it's embarrassing simple
so git is all about tracking the changes
that happen
to files on your hard disk
it's not really a source control system
it looks
and acts like one but it's not really it
at the
at the basic level so
it also means that git doesn't really
have an opinion
on how you use it while all the other
source control systems
before by virtue of how they were
designed
they were pretty much forcing you to be
to use them in a certain way
git is more like uh lego
in the sense that it's whatever you make
of it
there is no one true way to use git like
there is no true one way
to use lego i mean after you've gone
after after you learn the basics of
putting two pieces together
it's whatever you make of it so git is a
very flexible tool
which also means that you can use it
however it fits you
and here is where the other problem lies
okay
so you are telling me that git is can be
used in pretty much
any way i want but how do i know
which way i want to use it
and here is where things get a bit
tricky so
what you can do is observe how
other people are using git how
it's working for them both individually
as well as
in their projects like working with
other people so how
how are other teams using git
and what works and what doesn't work and
once you observe all these things you
write them down
which is exactly what i've been doing
and
you up so i applied that knowledge to
your own experience
and in that way you sort of grow
the way to use git that fits your needs
and the needs of your team and the
project
so with all that out of the way what
is this talk about this stock
is a collection of
git habits so to speak
that are aimed at improving your
development
workflow and these habits i have
collected them
by many years now of observing how
people are using git
and what works and what works maybe
less and these
habits they apply on two levels because
git
you i'm sure you know is a distributed
source control system
which means it has always two dimensions
you use with you use it on your own
computer individually
and that's one dimension and and then
you use it in the context
of a development project and that that's
when you use it inside
of a team when you're collaborating with
others
so all these habits they start with you
sitting on your computer and then they
expand
and they expand into the collaboration
aspect
so that's how i organized all everything
that i'm going to show you in this stock
falls in either one of those two
categories
so let's get started shall we
i talk way too much so i told you that
there is an individual dimension for
using it
and i call that dimension personal
workflows
the collaboration aspect of git i call
them team workflows
so these are the two main pillars for
this talk
and to give you a little bit more
structure
i organized my content in three
categories of workflows that you can use
individually and three categories of
workflows
that apply to your team and they sort of
build
on each other so without further ado
let's get started with the first one
and for that i'm gonna jump right over
into dem mode so what you see
on the uh left side which is here
which might as well be your right side
i'm not really sure how this
mirroring works anyway on one side there
is a
console terminal and
on the other side is where i'm going to
show you the
text for what i'm trying to tell you so
keep an eye on
both those two and so what
somebody wondering are you telling me
that everything that i'm
going to look at today is applies only
to the command line
well no what i'm going to show you
up most of it applies just as well to
both the command line
as well as the if you're using it
through any of the many
graphical user interfaces out there and
if there is something that just applies
to the command line i'm going to
highlight it for you so let's get
started with the first category
of a personal workflows
and that is get comfortable
so what does this mean this means that
you should configure git
exactly to make it a more
comfortable tool to work with
and in this first category and this
applies
just if you're using it on the command
prompt
is to install a git aware prompt now
what in the world is that a gitaware
prompt
is simply an a script or a some kind of
utility
that enriches your command line
and and adds information that is git
specific so for example you see over
here
that i'm for example here i'm looking at
the name of the branch i'm on
and as you see later throughout this
talk um
that information is updated as i modify
files and i
pull changes and push changes and stuff
like that so having that information
right in front of you at all times
certainly helps now what prompt should
you install
well that depends on which operating
system you're on
if you're using windows and maybe you're
using the new windows terminal
and you're using powershell as your
shell
then i highly recommend that you install
poshgit which is a gitaware prompt
for of course a powershell if you're
using linux
then there is bash git prompt which is
everything is open source of course
and then there is my personal favorite
starship which is the one
you are looking at over here and
starship is cross-platform so you can
use it
everywhere so that's the first one
the second one is i call it pretty diffs
now
and this also applies only to the
command line because if you're using a
gui then
that's the the thing that's going to
show you the diffs
so um when you use git you're going to
look at
a lot of patches differences between two
versions of the same file
now there is no reason why you shouldn't
make it as pretty as possible
so for example
let let me um well
let's go let's go ahead and i'm going to
tell you right away what what it is i
want to say
so there is an mpm module
which is called diff so fancy
which you can install like but like say
by saying npn install does
g diff so fancy g for global
once you've done that you need to tell
git to pipe
all the diff information through diffs
of fancy before it gets printed on the
screen
and the way you do that is by setting
the core dot
pager option so here you're basically
saying
to git all diff information should
be piped through dips of fancy and then
of course it pipes it
to less to give you paging and the
ability to scroll up and down
now once you've done that your divs are
going to look
much better than before so to
demonstrate this to you
let me first compare
the commit that came before the one i'm
currently on
with the one i'm on right now and now
i have already gives configured fancy so
i'm going to take it to ignore the pager
right now
to just show me how a regular diff would
look like
and of course you know you recognize
this format you have a bunch of other
information
over here and then you have the classic
plus
and minus for modified lines now this is
fine
for most cases but we can do better
so here is how it looks like
once you have diffs of fancy activated
which of course i mean it's obviously
much better
it also shows you exactly which part of
a line
has been modified between two versions
by highlighting it for you over here
so yeah definitely prettier divs
moving on speaking of making your
environment comfortable
is to let git handle white space for you
now as programmers will know that white
space matters
while it turns out that git has built-in
features
to make sure that your team
once you're agreed upon how you want to
for example handle indentation
to make sure that everybody on your team
is conforming to the agreed upon
white space handling rules
so how do you do that well there is an
option called
core dot white space and in this option
you are basically telling it what it
should consider
to be invalid white space
so in this case core
dot white space in this case i'm telling
it that i don't want
any white space at the end of a line
and i don't want any white space at the
end of a file either
and of course my favorite one is that i
don't want to see
any tabs used for indentation only
spaces
which of course everybody knows is the
correct way to do indentation right
so once you've done that you can
basically every time you modify your
files
you can do a quick check using the check
option of git tiff
and git will tell you if you are
breaking any of those rules
so for example let me open up this this
is just a c-sharp
program that does basically nothing so
let's
change something and add a bunch of
white space so maybe i'm
adding a comment over here and then
at the end of the line i add a bunch of
white space
in the end so let's save this
and if i now say git if check
git is telling me hey you have trailing
white space and it even tells me on
which
line so with this gives me
the option to fix it before i commit it
and as you're gonna see later on you can
also automate this step
so and you don't have to remember to uh
every time
run div check
so the next one is
conflict handling now of course if you
are working in a team
you are sooner or later gonna run into
merge conflicts they are just a fact of
life now git is
famous for being very good at handling
merge conflicts and why what because
it's a distributed source control system
where everybody is working
asynchronously so the chances that
you are going to have merge conflicts
are even higher than if you had a
traditional
centralized source control system where
for example you have exclusive checkout
rules where
only one person at a time can modify a
file
so let me just get rid of
the change so
what can you do well
uh the default way of showing you merge
conflict and this applies both to the
command line
and as well as if you're using a gui is
to show you
each side of the of the merge conflict
so in this example
i have a another branch called feature
and i know for a fact that this branch
contains a merge conflict
so let's go ahead and try to merge
feature
into master and here we go we are having
a merge conflict so let's take a look
at how the diff looks like and of course
you recognize this you see
how the conflicting line looks like on
one side of the of the conflict
and then you see it how it looks like on
the other side
sometimes this is enough to be able to
decide what the final
line should look like however
git can do better than that there is an
option
which is called conflict style and if
you set it to
diff 3 git is going to activate
its three-way merge feature
which is absolutely the best so
let's do it config merge dot i don't
know why this is not the default by the
way
beats me conflict style
you set it to d3
and now let's do the same merge again
oh sorry i was in the middle of the
other merge so let's abort that
and let's merge feature again
of course we're getting the same
conflict so let's take a look at how the
div looks like
and now i have three versions of the
line
i have the one side and the other side
like i did before
but now i have the common ancestor
which is how did this line look like
before
either one of those two commits so this
is really helpful in
deciding okay how did the common parent
of those two commits how did the line
look like
in that one and how how was it modified
in the two conflict in um
commits so this is
information that is going to help you
resolve the merge conflict
so really awesome stuff enable it
because
yeah it's it's great
the uh this concludes the first
part of category of
personal workflow of configuring these
are just
a few of the options there are many more
but these are just few of the options
that you can enable
to make git a more effective tool to
work with
let's switch gear and talk about the
second
thing regarding personal workflows
which is craft your history now
this is regardless if you are working on
a project by yourself
or you're working in a team however if
it's on a team it's even more important
is to take care of ensuring that your
the history of your source code is
readable
not only by you but of course by your
teammates and future generations of
programmers are gonna
have to work on the code base now
what does it mean to have a good looking
history
again by observing uh how many different
teams
work with git and in different kinds of
projects
i have identified four
traits of a good looking
history
and those four traits make up the
acronym
acid so is nice and easy to remember
so the first one the a stands for
autonomous
and this means that each commit
should make one logical change
doesn't mean that it's one physical
change i mean of course you can have
many modified files in a commit
but all those changes must be related
to the same thing to the same goal
and that should be independent from what
other commits do
now to do this you can there are two
ways to do this
way number one is that as you're working
on your source code
you are really disciplined and you
do just one thing at a time for example
if you are fixing a bug
you are not also making a refactoring
you fix the bug and then you create a
commit and then you go back and do the
refactoring so by being really
disciplined at all times
that's one way to make sure that every
committee does one thing
that's a lot to ask the other way is
you work just the way you prefer
you do your own thing and then at the
time of commit
you split your changes so that they are
compar
they are in different compartments uh
so you isolate each logical change from
the
others how do you do that so let me just
change to a different directory here we
have the same plot
project with the uh the so
one source code file code program
so the first way to do that is by doing
a
so-called patch commit now
and this is something that you can do
either on the command line
and a lot of the better you get
you guys they also let you to
let you do this graphically so how do
you think on the command line
let's say that i'm opening up this
source code file
which is the same as before and now i
am looking at it and i'm seeing that
right over here
there is a syntax well there is a this
doesn't even compile
so that was one hell of a bug so there
is an error here
however while i'm looking at this error
i'm also noticing that hey maybe this
using statement is and is unused
of course i'm not going to let it be
there i'm going to remove it so
i want to make these two changes and
those are two logical
different logically different changes
because one is a functional
change this one over here and the other
one
is more of a you can call it a refactory
i'm removing an
unused line of code
so i'm not going to do it one at a time
i'm going to do both at the same time
since i'm working in this file so let's
go up to line 10
let's remove this and then let's go to
line 9
and let's add the the i
that's missing in red line
so now if i do git if i see that
i have two different changes now i want
to commit them
separately from each other now if this
was any other source control system
i will have no choice but commit
everything at once
in git ike instead of saying git add and
then the
path of the file i can add the patch
option and what kit does it it looks at
the
total number of changes to diff and it
splits them up
and it's asking me hey do you want to
stage this hunk and here the word hunk
doesn't mean what you think it means
it means hank in in the universal div
format which is a standard a hank is
just a section
of a patch file so
do you want to stage this and then i'm
going to say
no n for no and then it goes on to the
next one and say do you want to stage
this hunk and then you say yes with the
y
and once you've done that you see that
my starship
git prompt is showing me that i have
one staged file and one modified file on
my working directory
so if i do git status i see that the
same file
is simultaneously staged and on stage
so how do i how can i look like how can
i look at what's about to be committed
i say giptif states
and this is showing me the stuff that
i've staged which is the bug fix
and if i say just kid if it's showing me
what's left in the working directory
which is not going to be
committed so pretty useful stuff
and as i said you can do this through
many of the the better the more powerful
git gui's out there
the next one in the acid acronym is
correct
now what does it mean it means that
every individual commit
should not break the state of your
project
that means you should not add any
compilation errors
nor should it add any failing tests
but how do you ensure that every
individual commit
doesn't break things and by the way why
would you want to do that
well if you imagine a scenario where in
your team you have people working on
multiple branches
and maybe one of your co-workers has
working on a
is working on a feature branch and is
also at the same time fixing a bug that
you also have on your branch
maybe you want to just pick
that one commit because every commit is
autonomous
you want to pick that one commit that
fixes the bug
and none of the other commits that add
the feature
and you want to apply that on your own
branch so that you can
you know continue working now in order
to be able to do that
reliably you need to have this
common trust in your team that
everyone's commits
you can apply them to any branch
and you won't have to deal with
compilation errors or
failing tests that's a basic assumption
for this to work
and if everybody agrees on this then
you'll be able to
exchange commits with each other and
keep on working in a more effective way
so the that every committee is correct
is
a a um is fundamental to being effective
when working with others but how do you
ensure that every commit
by itself doesn't break anything so one
way to do it
is to use the stash now if you may or
may not know about the stash the stash
is
a third place the other two being the
index
the staging area and the commits it's a
third place where you can
save modified files
now there is one lesser known feature in
the stash
that's called keep index what this does
is well let me just show you now i have
um i have staged a change and then i
have
another change that's not going to be
committed however
it's still on my working directory now i
want to make sure that
this change by itself
is correct without and also exclude
anything else from my working directory
so the way to do that is to say get git
stash save
and then i tell git you know what stash
everything that i have in my working
directory
but keep the index untouched
so when i do that and i say git stash
list now i have a stash
with the change however if i look at the
index that my my state change is still
there
which means and that's all i have
so if i look at the status you see i
don't i no longer have
anything modified in my working
directory because that's been stashed
away
so what you can do now is that you can
run your build script in this case
adjustable.net build
and verify that what's about to be
committed
indeed doesn't break anything
so now i can go ahead and say commit m
fixes debug compilation
error
but then i want to get back my changes
from the stash of course so at this
point i say git stash
pop and it's
being dropped from the stash
so because you don't want to accumulate
too much stuff in the stash it's like
the attic everything you put there stays
there forever
so um you want to remove it from that
however you want to put it back in your
working directory so now
if i do the status i have my
change back so that's that's great
let's get rid of that
another thing you can do is that when
you're working on a feature branch
you're gonna be making a bunch of
commits
now maybe you have forgot to um
to run this skip index step because it
is an extra step
you know on your workflow of course so
how can you ensure that
what the commits you have right now in
your branch individually don't break
anything
and this is where the rebase command
come in
all things now the rebase command is
probably the most infamous one in in
among all git commands and that's
probably because it does
too much it doesn't follow the single
responsibility rule
the git rebase does a bunch of things
and one of the thing it does is it
allows you to run
a command after
each commit in a sequence so let me show
you what i mean
what so if i look at the history of my
branch
and i'm working in master but if i look
at the history of my branch
i know that at some point one of these
commits
broke things because right now before i
fix the compilation error i had it in my
in my branch
so one of these commits over here is
breaking things
now how do i know which one breaks
this is where git rebase comes in if i
say git rebase
and then in this case i want to go back
all the way
at the beginning of history so i say
root
otherwise you can specify what is the
starting commit
that you want to check
and then you say exact and then you
specify which command do you want to run
for each of those commit
commits and of course if you have a
build script you will run your build
script in this case i'm just going to
run
dotnet build and you don't
have to do it interactive but i'm just
gonna add it
so to to show you what what it does
interactive
so here are the commits included in the
sequence
and you see for each one of them git has
added
the command that i specified so this
means that
git is going to go back to the first
commit and
run dotnet build for with the changes
included there
and if the dot that build command exits
with
zero which means everything went fine
it's gonna move on to the next one and
so on until the last
if the command you run x is with
something other than zero
which mean this means that something
went wrong and the rebase command is
going to stop
right at the commit that broke things
just like it will stop if you
encountered a merge conflict so
let's just go ahead and run and this is
running for the first one everything is
fine
and now it stopped and it said
execution failed and
here is also where having a
gitaware prompt really helps it's
telling me i'm at commit
4 of 10 and then i can inspect
the committee time i'm at right now and
indeed
this is the commit that introduced the
failing line and now i have a chance to
fix it and continue the rebase
pretty awesome stuff if you ask me
so let's move on to the
i in acid that means incremental
what does it mean it means that as you
are building up the commits in your
branch in your feature brands
or bug fix brands or whatever it is you
want those commit to
show your logical the logical
progression
your thought process so to speak that
went into those changes
why do you do you ask well because if
someone is going to look at your history
they're going to look at a sequence of
commits
and if those commits are in the order
in which things that in in order to make
sense for example if i'm going to
do a refactoring i'm going to do it
first and if i add a feature i'm going
to do it afterwards not the other way
around
it's going to help to understand how the
code transformed from one stage to the
other
but how do you do that you ask well meet
rebase again in this case in this case
we we're just using the in rebase
interactive like
we just did to reorder
the commits in a branch or possibly
if two commits are actually making the
same change
which means they are not autonomous if
you remember
you can squash them together and turn
two commits or more
into this into one so in this case
we know that we just run git rebase xx
so we know that the second commit
broke the code however we fixed it
over here now
we haven't shared this history with
anyone yet it just exists on our
computer
well on my computer and
so you have we have a chance to go back
and rewrite history
so that this commit never actually broke
anything
so we want to take this one and
make it so that it becomes part of the
first commit
and how do you do that well you say git
rebase
interactive and then in this case i'm
going to start from the beginning again
and what you do this is called the to do
file by the way because you're telling
it okay
what should happen for each one of those
commits
you take this one over here and you
literally
move it up to be below
the commit that you want to squash it
into
then you say fix up now what does fix up
mean
it says it right over here it squashes
the commit
but discards the log commit methods
because of course if you're gonna
make this commit part of the previous
one we're not really interested
in keeping this commit message around
so once you've done that you can save
and by the way you can do this
interactively based
also through to get guise
and that was really quick so let's look
at our history again
and now you see that that commit is no
longer here
it got squashed into this one so let's
look at
this commit let's look at its patch
and you see that it still adds the line
but now it's adding the correct line and
not the wrong one
the last one in this sec first section
is the d
and that's that's for documented what
does it mean
pretty self-explanatory it means that
we know that every commit should make
one logical change
isolated from the other they should be
correct
but they should also state in with as
much detail as possible what it is that
they are changing
now it turns out that you do that of
course in the commit message
turns out that there is a format to how
you should
um yeah format your commit message
and what format is that well first you
should have one sentence
which is nice and short and
this just describes at the um
at the highest level what this change is
about and that's called the summary
and the summary should be at the most 50
characters
after that you keep an er you set an
empty line and then you have the
so-called body
and the body can contain any amount of
detail that's necessary to understand
the change
you can also ref if you have us of
course if you're working in a team
you're going to have an
issue tracker you can also mention the
issue tracker number in the body
and some something that i've seen some
teams
do is that if you are doing pair
programming
you know git by default just records one
author for every commit
but if if there were two of you working
on that change
maybe you want to record both of the
authors well the way you do that
is in the body you can add a field
which is one or more co-authors and then
you
basically follow the same git format for
uh for the author with the name last
name and email address
and this way you can specify other
authors
that were involved in that commit
pretty useful because if the original
author maybe is no longer with the
company
you have one or more other person people
you can ask about
the background information of the change
the third and final category for the
personal workflows
is automation now git has a
a lot of automation built in and you
should really take advantage of it to
automate
the workflow both that you decide to
work with
on your own as well as your team
workflows
now the first one in this this means of
course letting uh
get to the work for you the first one is
alias functions
now you may have heard and this
only applies to the command line you may
have heard about
guitarists so for example if you don't
want to type
check out every time you can define an
alias
called for example co and now you can
say
git co feature to switch to another
branch
now these are simple analysis what you
may not know
is that you can assign a shell
function to an alias
and in that shell function you can have
entire scripts
that run associated to a simple
alias now one that i came up with a few
years ago that i'm still using daily and
i share with everyone
is get undo
now this is a shell function let me show
you how how it looks like
first i start my alias with an
exclamation mark
which is telling it that it should
interpret whatever comes afterward it
should run it
as a shell command it should just pass
the string to the shell in this case
bash then i define a shell function
which can be called anything i just call
it f and in the body
i'm just doing a reset hard
however this syntax over here
is a parameter because if you're
defining a shell function
shell functions can accept parameters so
that means you can pass parameters
to your alias and include that in the
function
and at the end of the function i just
simply invoke it
now what does this do let me show you
let's say that
um i make a commit in this case i just
don't
i don't want to make any change so i'm
saying allow empty
and i make a commit that says i'm about
to
regret this
and now i make another commit also allow
empty and then i'm going to say
and and and these two
so now if i look at the history
i have two commits that i want to get
rid of
now there is an any number of way i can
do that but if with my undo alias
i can say git undo and it's like
having the back button in your browser
how many times do you want to press the
back button or how many times do you
want to press
ctrl z well in this case i wanted to
undo the last two actions that i did
so i say git undo too
now if i look at the history again
you see that those two are gone so i've
and
i've undone my latest two commits
and this is just one example of the many
things you can automate by using
alias functions
so moving on this is my favorite
reuse recorder resolutions now let me
first change to a different one
now when you work on a feature branch
and you keep that branch
around for a long time and we are gonna
talk about it
in just a few minutes uh you are
probably going to be rebasing it a bunch
of times
and if there are any conflicts between
your feature branch and whatever is in
your stable branch
you will be resolving the same conflicts
over and over
because every base is about
applying each of your commits on top of
the
the one you're basing on one at a time
so if you replace multiple times you're
going to be resolving the same merge
conflicts
now git has an automation feature built
in
which is called rere
isn't it an awesome name which stands
for reuse recorder resolution
now this is something you need to enable
so let's go ahead and do that
so you say ray rere enabled
through and now it's enabled
forever by the way remember that this
just applies to your own repository so
everybody on your team has to do this
and now so we are on this same project
where we are on the feature branch
and we know from before that there is a
conflict between master and feature
now when you're working on a feature
branch for a long time
one technique that you can use to make
sure that
you are up to date with whatever is
happening on the main branch
is to to do a so-called test merge
so let me show you how this works and of
course you have this enabled
so i'm going to say i'm going to merge
master
into my feature branch by doing a
regular merge so no rebase
just to show you now you see that right
now
of course we are running into the same
merge conflict
however this time you see there is an
extra line in the output that says
recorded pre-image
for that file now the way rarer works
is that every time there is a merge
conflict git
records both sides of the conflict so
it records how the line looks like
on either side of the merge conflict and
what happens then
then when you resolve the conflict it is
going to
remember or record what the final line
looked like
so when it encounters the exact same
conflict it's going to automatically
reapply your previous resolution so let
me show you how it works
so now we have a merge conflict
and let's resolve it again
so in this case you see one side is
removing the exclamation mark
over here and the other the other side
is adding a comma so this is the common
parent so let's decide
that the final line is going to have
the comma but it's not
going to have the exclamation mark
so this is how i want my final line to
look like
so i save the modified file
looks like this now all i have to do of
course
is to add it to the index
and now i continue my merge
let's just save this and you see what
git says now it says recorder resolution
for this now yes i've recorded a
resolution
but if i look at the
um at the history i now
also have a merge conflict and as you're
going to see in a few minutes
this is not something that you want on a
feature branch
because that complicates history how
history looks like
we're going to talk about in just a few
minutes so
you i don't want to keep this merged
merge commit around
so what am i am i going to do i'm going
to undo it with my
undo alias and now
i'm back to however it was before
without
the the merge merge commit
however git has recorded my resolution
so what happens if i merge master again
now this time git is telling me hey i
resolve
i i had a conflict but i have resolved
it
using the previous resolution so let me
look
let's let's take a look at how it looks
like yeah it is showing me
exactly how the lines looked like before
and how they are looking like
how the line is looking like now so it
has reapplied
my previous resolution so at this point
i can just of course
add this to the index and continue on
now the thing that's useful is that
remember
when i a rebase operation is also a form
of merge
however you're just merging one commit
at a time instead of merging
two branches in one go
so this means that if i now were to
rebase
my feature branch on top of master
it is going to reuse
the same resolution even during
a rebase so of course it's going to stop
because it
encountered an emerge conflict however
if i look at the state of my working
directory you see that the conflict has
already been resolved
so i can i can simply say git rebate of
course i need to add it to the index
and then i can simply say git rebase
continue
and i'm done with my rebase
incredibly useful stuff the last one i
want to share with you is client side
hooks now
every time you do something on your
local repository and even on the server
like you're pushing commits
or you are creating a commit locally
there are events that happen
and that git git is raising events for
everything that happens
inside the repository now
you can associate shell scripts that run
as a response to those events
and why would you want to do that again
if you have agreed upon a convention in
your team
and you want to make sure that everybody
is following that convention
without adding more burden on their
workflow
you can automate it for them
so you can distribute a bunch of
client-side hooks
that your teammates will have to
download into the repositories
because sadly client-side hooks cannot
be shared from this
from a central repository and then they
will automate stuff for them so for
example
remember the the white space checking
there is a merge there is a clan side
hook called pre-commit
that happens just before the commit is
created
and the argument um
of that hook is the changes that you are
about to apply
so that's a perfect um occasion to run
a white space check just right before
the commit is done
so it's gonna stop if you are about to
introduce any white space errors
the other one is another event that's
happening
when the committee is about to be
created however this time
the argument of the event is the commit
message
and this is a perfect case to validate
that your commit message is conforming
to the rules that you have agreed upon
so for example i have a um by the way
these commit hooks
they live inside a the git directory
called hooks there is a bunch of them
you have a bunch of sample scripts that
are already made
so the way you activate it is you remove
the sample extension
and you write the code in the for the
for the shell that you're using
so in this case i have one called commit
a message that checks the format of the
commit message
so let me show you how it works let's
say that i want to make a commit
now empty and now i'm breaking the rule
of
making the first line be 50 characters
so
this summary is way longer than
the 50 characters that
it should be and now the commit hook
has been activated and it's printing me
hey
the first line should be 50 characters
but yours was 70.
what do you want to do do you want to
modify it in an editor
or just commit it and of course i'm
going to say why yes
and you see that even the editor is
showing me that
whatever is white and many git guys do
this for you
they're gonna highlight when you're past
the fifth character
in the summary showing me that
everything after that
is a is longer so this
summary is way longer than 50. let's
remove that
and now my commit message is conformant
to the to the rules
and with that we are done with the
personal workflows now let's
go back and take a look at
the team workflows
and these are of course also divided
into three categories
the first one of these three categories
is branching now um i'm sure you're
familiar with
all the different kinds of flows
that exist out there there is git flow
this is github
flow and is whatever flow
which one should you use for your
project
now the answer you should be asking
that your team should be asking is not
which flow
you should use but rather what do we
need
if you've been looking at the original
blog post
for git flow the original author has
published an
update just this year in april or march
where he said that yes this blog post is
10 years old now
and basically saying what everybody um
already knew is that git flow was
designed
and it came out of a specific situation
it was designed to conform a certain
team constellation
and a certain kind of software project
that's where it worked
it unfortunately it became some kind of
some standard that everybody and every
team on earth
was applying this same workflow
regardless of
whether their project and team match the
preconditions
upon which git flow was designed
so this is all to say that
instead of focusing on taking a
ready-made
flow and apply it as is to your project
instead you should consider what it is
what kind of software you are building
and whether you are have to maintain for
example multiple versions
uh in production at the same time or you
have just one version at any time like
in a web application
and of course how many members on your
team and what their experience level is
using it those are all factors
that have they have to influence your
choice of flow
and the right answer is usually that
there is no flow that you can use
as is you can be inspired by one or more
of the different flows
and adapt it to your specific needs
now when it comes to adapting a flow
what should you think about them
well one way to guide you in this choice
is to think about
what kind of branches do you use in a
project
so be aware that there are a finite
finite uh set of branches
what are they well the first two kinds
of branches
are long-running branches which are the
branches that exist for as long as the
project runs for master is the canonical
long-running branch and then there are
topic
branches topic branches are branches
that are focused on
solving a particular problem or task so
they are short-lived
so for example let's say that this is
the history of a project
this is the master branch the
long-running branch that is shared among
everyone
and then there is you from the master
branch you will
be creating one or more possibly more
topic branches that are focused on uh
working on different features for
example
so these are the topic branches
now the way you merge the work done in a
topic branch into the long running one
is by doing a merge commit after that
the original topic branch is deleted so
there is no record of what the branch
was called
however you still have the merge commit
to tell you that that work was done
in parallel
the other kind of branches that you can
create
are public branches and
private branches now remember git is a
distributed source control system
so what does this mean it means that
you will be having a shared repository
now in git
all repositories are created equal there
is in no
implicit primary or central repository
like there was in a centralized source
control system
where there was the server every
repository is equal to all the others
now you just so happen to agree on that
one copy
one repository is deemed the canonical
one
and you put it on a central server like
for example github
or azure devops or whatever you're using
now everybody on the team is also going
to have a local
copy of the repository a local
repository which is exactly the same as
the shared one
so and that will exist on their own
computer
now a branch that exists
on the shared repository the one that
everybody has access to
that is called a public branch
and any branch that you create on your
own computer
before you push it push it anywhere
there is
a private branch private to you
now this is an important distinction to
make
because long-running branches
those are usually public because a
long-running branch is usually shared
so multiple people are going to merge
their changes into the long-running
branch
a topic branch on the other hand that
you create to implement a feature or
fix a bug those are usually private
so remember this association
long-running branches are public
topic branches are private
now this doesn't always have to be the
case you could have a private branch
that you keep around for a long time
and as you have seen there are there are
things you can do
to minimize the work you have to do to
keep resolving the same merge conflicts
for example by using
rare ram so
you can of course keep around a private
branch for a long time that turns it
into a private long-running branch
by the same token you could have
multiple people in your team
be collaborating on solving the same
topic so for example if you decide to
create a branch
for every user story that if you're
using some kind of agile process
and so you're creating a topic branch
for its user story
then it's very likely that more than one
developer is going to work on that user
story
and that means that you're going to be
sharing the topic brands on
the central repository the shared one
and that turns it into a public one
so there can absolutely be topic
branches that are public
however these combinations are not the
same
so long-running public branches
absolutely that's okay
and private topic grounds is that's also
okay
however long-running private branches
those are problematic for the reasons
that we have been looking at
you're gonna be you're gonna the longer
you keep a
branch private the more you're gonna
stray away
from the the shared one and even if you
have features like
rarer you'll still be you will you will
be encountering
more and more immersed conflicts to
merge like new ones
but the same token sharing a feature
branch
between multiple people is also a
problem why is that
because a topic branch remember the i
in acid incremental you will often
be reordering commits and squashing
commit into it into other ones so you
will be
rewriting history a lot in a topic
branch because
that's what it's designed for to solve a
particular problem
now if you have multiple people working
on a topic branch
and you do a rebase and you squash
commits and you change the order
that's gonna mess things up for the
other ones because you know that every
time you rewrite history
every commit gets a new id and if the
other people working on the same feature
branch have created new commits
on top of the old ones and then you
publish your own
rewritten commits that's going to create
a mess
so be aware of those combinations
so long-running public branches yes you
should have them
but you should be limiting the number
of branches that you keep around that
are both long-running
and also that are public so branches in
those categories
be conservative with them because they
are a
pain to handle on the other hand
topic branches that are pra and private
branches
that's what kit is for creating a branch
is a
cheap operation so you should be doing
it like there is no tomorrow
so be liberal with that those kind of
branches take advantage of git branching
model
to um to your to to be more effective
with your work so keep as many topic
branches that are private
as as you want
now the now that we talked about
different kind of branches
we should also talk about different ways
of merging
now the kinds of branches that you have
decide
the merge strategy so there are of
course two kinds of mergers there are
the true merges and then there are the
uh rebases so
what how should you merge this kind of
branches well the public branch
let's say you have a public branch that
you want to merge into another public
branch
in that case you want to have a visible
merge commit between them
if you're merging a public branch into a
private one
then you want to have a rebase so for
example if you have a pull request being
merged into master
you want to make it visible with a merge
commit and if you are merging master
into your own working progress branch
then you want to do a rebase and why is
that well
if you have a public branch like this
and you have a pull request
you're also public and you merge them
well
let's say that uh then something turns
up
that the the pull request introduce a
problem of some kind of bug
well if you have a merge commit it's
easy because you can revert that merge
commit and it automatically reverts
everything that came in with that merge
commit if instead you had rebased
your pull requests and done this kind of
fast forward merge and there is a
problem with any of those commits then
you have to track them down
and revert them manually and the longer
uh
the more commits to be been built upon
afterwards the harder it's going to be
so what you want to do instead is to um
oh by the way why do you want to re
speaking of rebates why do you want to
rebase
your topic brands and not merge well
let's say that you are
merging like we did before master into
feature
and then at some point later if you keep
that merge commit around
you're gonna merge this back into master
now you see that history is going
to look a lot more complicated than it
has to be and if you
do this enough your history is going to
look like this
which is another way of calling it is
guitar hero history
why because if you squint it looks like
this
you definitely don't want that instead
what you want
is you want to rebase your private
branch on top of the public one
and then do a fast forward merge for a
nice linear history
third one is releasing this is a quick
one now that you have multiple branches
different kinds of branches different
ways of merging you should be aware of
where the code that is in those branches
is going to
which means every branch that is shared
should be
mapped to an environment so that means
that if you have a master branch and
then you have a another long-running
branch called develop
develop could be the place where you
put work towards the next version of
your software
so that in that case every commit is
going to a test environment where it's
going to be qa
the master branch instead contains the
stable version of the software
that's currently in production so when
you merge the work
that you've done in develop that has
been verified in the test environment
you want to push it out to production so
that your customers can use it
now the way you deploy from these
branches is also different
maybe in the developed rounds you want
to automatically deploy
every single commit so that it can be
tested in that case you are doing
continuous deployment
the master branch you maybe want to be
more conservative you can be doing
continuous deployment there as well
however it's more likely that you want
to do you want to be able to commit at
any time
however the actual commit trigger should
not be automatic but should be an
explicit action that you do
and with that i'm a few minutes over so
i hope you guys
stayed around for a for the last part i
want just to summarize
we have talked about personal workflows
and among personal workflows uh is to
get comfortable
configure git to to be a more pleasant
tool to work with
make sure to craft your history so that
it follows the rule of acid
and it's nice and readable and
deploy as many automation features that
that you can
to automate the workflow that your team
agrees upon
so that you don't have to think about it
then we also talked about team workflows
and team workflows they all are around
the concepts of the different kinds of
branches that you will be managing
so i was very intentional not to give
you advice on which flow to use
but instead giving you guidance on how
to evaluate a different kind of
workflows
based on the kinds of branching branches
and of course once you have different
kinds of branches you also have
different
merge strategies so being aware of how
to handle those two
and the last one is being aware of how
you want to release software
from your branches which environment are
going to and how often
are you going to deploy to those
environments
with that let's just give you a pointer
to
everything that i've shown you and more
is available on a pre-asset course that
i have out which is called advanced tips
and tricks
this uh this course includes a lot of
what we've been seeing here and
and more so so here is a link
to that and with that i want to say
thank you for watching and if you have
any question you can reach me
at either one of those addresses or on
the slack i'll be
monitoring for the rest of the day as i
said thank you and
enjoy the rest of the conference